overwhelmingly a lot of them are just
lonely a lot of them have trouble with
just platonic friendships too and don't
feel they have like a
strong social group and a lot of them
just aren't happy the vast majority of
them have some kind of like either
depression or anxiety something like 20
are on the autism spectrum which is a
really really high percentage and that's
formal diagnoses too not just that
suspect that they are
namicates welcome in the show
thanks for having me
how did you get into researching in
cells
i've been asked this many times and i
don't have a neat story as to how
um
basically i have a background in media
i'm a filmmaker i've written things and
acted and
you know music everything kind of in
that world
um and
so i was uh finishing up the film when i
started really getting into podcasts
just as a medium
um
and the ones that i liked the most were
true crime
kind of stuff as you know crawl space my
network um is very true crime oriented
and um i was just listening to a lot of
them and i guess kind of having just
worked on a film that is very costly and
you know
labor labor-intensive time-intensive
planning intensive process
um also a visual medium which i've
since realized i'm much less visually
oriented than i am in terms of words and
sound and things like that um and
yeah i was just kind of really
appreciating that the medium like
storytelling through that form was
interesting to me and around the same
time
i think in cells kind of
made their way onto my radar
and
uh and then i i had a happenstance
encounter with one within with an incel
um i think in 2017 or so and it was just
a random social media thing
and i started talking to this person and
it became very interesting and i asked
if we could record our conversations and
he said fine and i listened to them back
and found them interesting and it just
seemed like a good
topic for a podcast you know i i looked
around for information about it and
there was hardly any at the time
and that's kind of how it started
but i asked all of twitter
for their suggestions and the two names
that came up as like in-cell experts
were you and james bloodworth
so you've managed to reach the pinnacle
of what twitter thinks an in-cell expert
is
yes
i also managed to reach the uh
whatever you would refer to as the
bottom of that okay bottom of the barrel
and at the top fine yes
that's cool all right so how do you
define what an in-cell is
well um there is
the basic definition involuntary
celibate in cell someone who is
involuntarily celibate um categorically
according to the insult community
would just be someone that
you know doesn't have
sexual or romantic relationships despite
wanting them
um
so that's kind of
the broadest definition and
there's also like a timeline
limit for for some groups they say you
know
you have to be a virgin someone say well
it has to be six months or more that
you're in this situation that you can
say you're you're in cell otherwise it's
a dry spell or something um so so
there's that but beyond that
um is
are we talking about an incel which is
just someone who is that whether or not
they
know it um or someone who
recognizes that they are an incel
um that's kind of the second or middle
of the road definition and then the
third i would say is someone whose
identity is
who who's really kind of made their
identity about that and partakes in the
online
you know community and the forums and
the websites
as we
all might be coming to know more about
them well pretty much everyone during
lockdown last year probably was an
insult unless you're exactly your
partner right
right and and everyone who um
you know everyone at some point in their
lives probably was one too obviously
there's some exceptions to that but yeah
um if you just go by that definition
okay so there's dry spell which is a six
month period
there's like
purity in cell which is someone that
hasn't had sex there's an incel which is
someone that's aware about the fact that
they're sort of struggling with women
and then there's somebody who identifies
with the community so you've sort of got
a bit of a hierarchy going on
yep
okay cool
how do in cells relate to the men's
rights movement do they at all
um
yes i mean again if we're going by the
categorical description of of an incel
um and by the way that's i and i don't
mean just the categorical description i
mean the one where they're aware of it
but they're not they don't associate
with the community in any way and i've
actually had many people like that on my
show so it's not uncommon you know these
are people who are in cells and who are
aware that they are unaware that a
community exists but they just don't
relate to a lot of what they see in
there it's kind of like a lifestyle but
not an identity
yeah or maybe even if it were an
identity
once they realized
what was associated with it or what the
identity was for most of the people in
it they didn't want anything to do with
it
so
um
the original question is sorry men's
rights men's rights okay so yeah
the men's rights of mra men's rights
activists um along within cells and
along with mgtow and going their own way
um and pua pickup artists
and some other sort of
you know
derivations are make up what's called
the manosphere now
um and the manosphere is
uh described in various places to be
kind of like a male supremacist
umbrella of groups that um have certain
things in common obviously with a lot of
differences between them um there's also
a timeline to this i don't know if you
want me to get like too detailed
about that just give us a broad overview
i want to know i want to know how this
all pieced together
okay so um
basically
i would say that around the time that
like 4chan 4chan which started in 2003
or 2005. i don't remember you know began
and a lot of different social media
platforms began they all kind of came of
age around the time which is the mid
thoughts late thoughts that there was
this pua pickup artist
movement and it started with this man
neil strauss who wrote a book called the
game
that was um
considered pretty controversial or or
misogynistic at one point but it was
basically just kind of game like how
men can
um
gamify the system when it comes to
human behavior and mating and what makes
people attractive to each other etc um
so this was a big
thing it was the book was a huge
bestseller um and
it kind of created a
a group of
dating experts um
think you could call them like gurus at
the time of pick up
this thing pick up art pickup artistry
um and there would be you know it became
another exploited adventure like there
would be weekend retreats that cost a
lot of money and all that stuff um and
while this was happening
um
and 4chan was becoming a thing with its
boards like uh r9k which was for
hikikomori a lot of the language that
they were
coming up with at the time
um and you could imagine there'd be some
overlap between people that spend too
much time on the computer and our young
men maybe aren't getting laid so there
was
um
and then pickup artists kind of
led to
like the next generation of young men
who felt awkward or whatever having
spent money and time and effort and
resources on these pickup artists camps
and this philosophy in these books and
and seeing that it didn't work for them
so
you know they became reactionary against
pickup artists and
um if you
are really into this stuff like i am
you'll know that
uh when people write about elliot roger
and they talk about the insult forms
that he visited uh the one that they're
referring to is what was called pua hate
p u
roger for the people that don't know
so elliot rogers like
the first incel
killer as as people would call him and
understand that he was a 22 year old who
um shot up his former
you know it was a college town that he
was living in near santa barbara in isla
vista and
you know he murdered seven people
so he left a very kind of widely
circulated manifesto and he had youtube
videos
um
he has a persona very much like a
american psycho kind of character like a
oscar wilde or you know very affected
kind of persona so that i think inspired
a lot of copycats and that was the first
attack that was associated with the
insult community though he himself never
used that word
um so yeah this is where pua pua hate
kind of started
and around the same time you had the
beginnings of the manosphere so all
these groups kind of coming up together
um
in reaction to
modern
society feminism
circumstances in their life
are they gay in cells or female in cells
um so that's a
you know a question i get a lot uh most
in cells themselves would say that there
aren't
uh either um
female in cells would call themselves
fem cells
and there is a femcel there are you know
like
themselves chats and servers and stuff i
haven't really seen a dedicated website
um it's a pretty different demographic
the nature of the conversations is very
different um and
most in cells don't think that
women
really can be in cell um they also don't
think that gay men can be in cell
because they think that women's
selectivity how how picky women are is
the reason that most of them are in cell
so when you remove the sexual gatekeeper
from the conversation you just have two
protagonists that can
go at it as much as they want
exactly
okay cool uh what is it about these
communities that makes them appealing
um
well that was a question that i raised
when i wrote about this which i think is
a very important question
what makes them appealing what makes any
um
counterculture appealing
what makes any fringe group appealing
um
i think there are
many things that do but for the most
part i think any time someone
you know really
creates like a new identity and finds a
new
um
purpose or like a sense of family and
community in an external community
that says that there was something
missing
from their life to begin with
they need to seek
you know externally to find this so i
think that that's what it is i think
that for a lot of people it just comes
down to feeling unimportant feeling
unseen
feeling ignored um and then with this
one it's even more obvious you know in
this community
they can speak
openly about
things that are very shameful
in other you know pretty much everywhere
else
all right so what sort of things do they
focus on like you've spent
far too long much far longer than is
healthy
engrossed in these sorts of chats what
is this sort of content that's in there
um
so
like in the forums or like when they
talk to me
or maybe
in the forums
so in the forums you will have a lot of
uh
ls people posting their l's that's kind
of american slang for posting their
losses
um a lot of commiserating a lot of
talking about
something bad that happened
uh today
you know and how like this this and this
happened you know proof that i'm really
subhuman there will be talk about um
the studies
from evolutionary psychology
or biology uh
that
um
you know
document
that less attract like the average
heights of
ceos or people respond to more
attractive people in terms of hiring
things like that uh you know tinder
data studies and
all kinds of stuff like that mostly is
that to legitimate the suffering in a
way to kind of give some statistics and
some quantifiable backups to what
they're experiencing qualitatively
yes 100
um
to validate it and also to offer some
kind of explanation
um but so far
it sounds like it's a place where people
that are struggling in life can find
other people that are also struggling
and they get like you say commiseration
they get support
but i imagine
that
this must lead to i know for a fact that
it leads to resentment right it's not
just commiseration of the in-group it's
resentment of the out group and the out
group would be women
the outgroup not just women but i mean
women's kind of the obvious one but it's
also just like normies i i would say in
the more mature
in cells that i speak to that do just
get what you're describing out of this
group which is
you know a sense of belonging and
oftentimes it's just kind of jokes humor
like it's gallows humor it's dark
it's memes but it's still humor
um
i i would say for
most and remember this is a community
that ski is very young but so the ones
that are a little bit older i think the
resentment is not just women but just
kind of society and the hypocrisy of
society for not um
acknowledging that people can be shallow
and people can be focused and all of
these things
um
but yeah it i mean
i've had many examples on
the show at this point that have either
said uh explicitly that they feel like
the community made things worse for them
in terms of their depression
um
and
somewhere i just see it's just not
helping
and then there are some that it does
help because they find that community
so many people that i've heard on your
podcast that uh black-pilled or
ex-members of this community
do really talk about it like almost like
leaving a cult
you know they talk about having seen the
light of something that was wrong and
then they've kind of come out but um
yeah it's it's weird right because on
one hand you think yeah if people are
struggling and they feel marginalized
then yes give them a support system
that's great but it's the slippery slope
when it can
encourage people to almost stay
like that i think you've said that
misery and failure are set almost sort
of celebrated
in these forums and that ascending and
making more of yourself is sometimes
sort of talked down to is that right
yeah i mean
not necessarily talked uh
or discouraged but um
because it has to be a community for
insults and there's the gatekeeping that
goes along with that too
um
people can be banned for
uh bragging you know that's one of the
main so if somebody was asleep if one of
the members was to finally sleep with
the woman
would that be classed as bragging yes or
even way less than that like that you
know they'll complain to me that i can
barely say anything on there anymore
because even if i just say that
like uh a female just talked to me today
then they'll be they'll call me a chat
and
so is that
how much of that do you think is the
community protecting itself from hope
that if one member of this community is
able to
make a tiny little bit of headway you
know one millimeter in the right
direction and and a girl says yes to
them that that then highlights the fact
that there's a potential for other
members to do that and that obviously
creates a delta between where they are
and where they want to be and it can
cause discomfort is that one of the
mechanisms yeah sure i mean as it is for
you know i think
friend groups in general when someone
kind of succeeds or other ones don't
um and then more specifically in this
community because
um you know to some degree rightly
they've uh
experienced bullying or teasing for
being
whatever it is they perceive themselves
to be
you know
to varying degrees obviously
um and they imagine that
this person is just larping to to bully
them or make fun of them or whatever
what's laughing
um live-action role-playing
okay does that mean like pretending
yeah okay okay so what are the
commonalities about amongst the people
that are in these communities other than
the fact that they're struggling with
women and not having sex
what other commonalities do you have
well um i would say that
overwhelmingly a lot of them are just
lonely in general so
um there are definitely exceptions to
this a substantial amount of them but um
for the most part um a lot of them have
trouble with
just platonic friendships too and don't
feel they have like a
strong social group and just with other
aspects of purpose and life a lot of
them just aren't happy
a lot of them
have
the vast majority of them have some kind
of um like either depression or anxiety
pretty significant
amount of it um something like 20
are on the autism spectrum
which is a really really high
percentage um and that's you know formal
diagnosis too not just that suspect that
they are um so compared to like one or
two percent
of the population
across the board that's very high
um
and
yeah bullying teasing
in in childhood um
a lot of them are
neat though that's not the majority
that's like a third and meat is
not in employment or educational
training so
they're under
employed under stimulated you know
um
and then
there's other there are other
um
many other commonalities but i mean
maybe if you have a question more
specifically about
uh
one the first time that i saw the word
neat was when the gamestop short squeeze
happened earlier this year
and they said that i can't believe wall
street's been taken down down by a bunch
of [ __ ] needs
right
yep but you see the intersection right
of all of these different cultures
coming together
what are their views of women then
so i would say that the views of women
are
women are spoiled
women are
privileged women are you know
uh systemically privileged
um
i think that in this
you know
with varying degrees of irony or
sincerity
so there's a range of this too but
uh
not
not faithful not trustworthy
um
selfish
um
obsessed with with attention you know
just attention
male attention specifically
more important than anything else
um
greedy i guess for for both
money and attention and chads
um
kind of uh almost primitive creatures
it seems interesting thinking about it
i agree that there is a um
there is an element of looks from male
to female attraction that doesn't always
get spoken about
but in my experience status and
resources can account for an awesome
awful lot of looks like think about the
old billionaire right that's got a
really hot
young wife
are there any of the guys that are
trying to sort of manipulate their way
out of in seldom through
status or acquiring forces
yes there are um
so they have their kind of uh
hierarchy of what's important to women
is looks money status in that order
oh really
yes do you agree with that
no
how would you put it
um i think it really varies from person
to person and i think personality
belongs on that list and they don't
um and then i i think that
i think it's a combination of
of all those things and one informs the
other two like we're uh they talk about
this concept of the halo effect which is
uh
an idea for when somebody is physically
attractive
um they are seen as being more
intelligent more funny more
kind you know the list goes on and i
think that there's plenty of truth to
that um
but i think the reverse works too you
know
uh to where if someone is very funny is
very intelligent is whatever they are
also seem to be more attractive more of
the other things
um
and
the blend for each person is very
different and it becomes really
difficult to know uh at some point
you know objectively and they're very
interested in ranking like i get asked
to rank or rate their appearance one to
ten all the time and i wouldn't even
know how to do that i i've never why do
you think that's the case
uh well i have a few
um
ideas about it i mean
obviously there's some rigid thinking
going on in this community some need for
rankings order
numbers
um
kind of a black and white thinking too
sometimes
that is
maybe a little bit more typically male
uh
to rank things like that
um
maybe a little bit more typically kind
of
uh of a conservative or less
sort of adventurous open-minded
personality which would track too and
then again you know with autism spectrum
disorder and i'm not trying to you know
i have to be very careful whenever i
even bring it up even though i think
it's so significant um but
that's also you know a
point of view personality type that
tends to be more rigid more putting
things in labels and ranks and
so you know i think all of those things
are are related and i think they're all
also important for people to consider
when they think about how to
deal with in cells so some of them have
identified the fact that looks are an
enabler for status and resources but
they also sort of rank uh the hierarchy
of these in reverse so looks first as
that
what about trying to make themselves
look more attractive isn't there
anything look smack looks maxing just
means
making yourself more attractive
physically
physically
yes uh there's other i mean
so if so status maxing is is a term too
that people can do
which i think is i always tell them go
for that that's very important
um more important than any of the others
um
jester maxing being funny that's their
term for it
you can gesture max your way into
ascension um
and
then
there's others too there's all kinds of
categories but um
the money one they
refer to differently as beta boxing so
that's not just maxing
um it's beta bucks and the reason they
don't all just try to do this is because
then
you
might be able to buy your way into
having a relationship or even getting
married or whatever but
uh
the woman will always be thinking of
chad because you're beta and she'll
never really be attracted to you or
really love you
um or be loyal to you and that's why
money
is the third of the three
or it's status the third of this
status is the third
that's interesting
well they think that um
two women
looks is most important than money and
then status i disagree again but
um that's not really ranking
outcomes
of
you know this isn't all airtight yes
it's not really ranking the outcomes of
working on
either
any of the three things it's just
beta beta gets a different category also
because it sounds good i guess
yeah wait rhyme's better right so yeah
you've mentioned before that the in
cells particularly feel sort of
marginalized in a modern woke culture
what's that mean
well that
i think i think there's truth to that
because
um
because of
you know
many of our current
uh movements i guess um and attempts to
sort of correct
um
portions of
our history that have been less
fair to
some identity or another um
men and a lot of people think of
themselves as being white men even
though that's that's not true it's about
half and half um
uh are
you know they're they're not very
high up on the
epistemology victimology scale it's kind
of on the bottom
so
i think that
where we do have a tremendous amount of
empathy or at least
formative at least the appearance of
empathy being granted to almost any uh
any group you can name now protected
class
um
there is none from
supposedly the more empathetic people
toward this group yeah empathy and
victimhood is sort of in vogue
at the moment right like signaling was
we're so compassionate we really care
about this marginalized group
why do you think it is that incels
aren't getting that same love is it just
that they're part of it
what would be a traditional oppressive
class i.e patriarchy
i i think that's where it starts
um i think there's also
quite a bit of
moral panic right now in our culture
over
um
issues like
racism and misogyny as there should be
but to then
ascribe
you know things that are not well
um just because
so so insults are this misogynistic
group uh from the privileged class of
men
um
and
so therefore
what they do that is
horrible is i i don't know it doesn't
entirely make sense to me but i guess um
there is a tendency now because
everyone's very polarized uh for
especially in sort of the mainstream to
really um
explain
anything that's horrible and ugly and
unwanted and reviled and you know
dangerous
into like um
something that we can say is just this
big that evil like racism or misogyny or
something and so i guess it's difficult
for people to imagine that if one
belongs to this group they can't also be
um deserving of
one can't be they don't neatly fit into
oppressor or oppressed
yeah yeah and also it's
it's derived from individual preferences
yeah and that's very hard how do you say
i'm angry at you
evolutionary programming like i'm angry
at you hypergamy
especially when everybody is at the
mercy it's like being angry at gravity
well if people accept that those things
are
they do actually
exist and not everyone does but yeah
yeah well
hopefully
i don't know i mean not it blows it
blows my mind the the blank slateism uh
i've got james budworth coming on i saw
that he had a conversation with um a
feminist series of letters and uh i was
blown away by the fact that most
feminists described to or she said that
most feminists apparently ascribe to
this sort of blank slate theory which is
that the only differences that you have
between men and women are because of
socialization you're like
you've read
nothing
i i don't understand
oh common sense i mean
really just a minimum of common sense i
think would suggest otherwise well if
that person is in a relationship
or if those people are in relationships
you'd say okay is your husband shorter
than you
probably not does your husband earn less
than you right is your husband less
educated than you does you have less
status than you i can almost guarantee
that it's not going to be two of those
four exactly
why is that there oh well you know we
just have uh well no that's preferences
where do you think they came from yes
like do you think that we just recreated
all the preferences that exist in the
animal kingdom through socialization so
we we dispensed with them every other
animal got them it's like do you know
what it is it's the
biological equivalent of flat earthers
i know that i can see out there
in the ether
spheres the atmosphere and the sun's a
sphere and all of these other planets
and and stars
but we're not but we've actually
re-invented it so that it kind of looks
and feels like we are right right always
occam's razor you know yeah
yeah so what about being pro monogamy
because i only learned kind of recently
about the um
the usefulness of monogamy is a
redistributive strategy for sex and i
guess that the in-cells are probably
quite pro-that
they are pro-monogamy
uh
generally because
so many of them
haven't even had a relationship that
well why wouldn't they be and and then
they have these fears about um
you know women being unfaithful so
it would make sense that they're
pro that i mean well on the flip side
sorry i i would have guessed that
in a different version of the world
they could have said well if a society
was more sexually liberal and women were
more free and open i might get laid more
easily so it doesn't necessarily
logically follow that monogamy that they
would be pro monogamy that's that's true
um and there are some that actually
think that way there are a few that do
think that way that because women are
you know more sexually liberated that
that actually works in their favor
but um where they don't is
you know what we kind of alluded to this
idea of enforced monogamy just that in
the past when women weren't so
hypergamous and didn't have these
endless options
um
there would be other reasons they'd have
to stay with
with someone um
and then maybe beta bucks wouldn't be
such a taboo thing
um but now that women have all these
options then they are only going to want
chad
um i think there's just a crossover more
generally between
kind of traditionalist
um
thinking
or
more issues with contemporary society
um
for for a number and in cells for a
number of reasons i mean
one
is i think kind of obvious of just what
we talked about with the
you know um
or maybe we didn't talk about it so much
about feminism and women's
um
financial
uh
women's ability to have agency and to
have a career problem with that
um
i don't think they have a problem with
it per se i think it's kind of what you
alluded to which is that
being that women now can do all those
things and sort of elevate themselves on
all these levels
but they still want a man that's
equal
yeah exactly that it leaves a lot of
them out you know it takes them out of
the this is i mean i've spoken about
this loads but it is so fascinating
what's happening when you've given women
the ability to earn status education and
resources off their own back and the
externality of it is so crazy and no one
could have predicted well maybe with
unbelievable foresight you might have
been able to predict but the fact that
women quite rightly should be allowed to
do what they want and become smarter and
richer and be more well-known more
famous
but that they're fundamentally going to
shrink their own dating pool by doing
this which leads to a bunch of
disassociated disaffected men
who only have other men to be friends
with and a bunch of singleton women
who are struggling to find a man that
they're fundamentally attracted to
and
then a bunch of like the only person
that's come out of this well are the
nines and tens
in the uh on the men's side like no one
else has come out of this in a good
situation yeah i i mean it's true and
you can't it's one of those things that
you can't
really like
no one would want to i wouldn't want to
obviously um not to say that anybody
would but even if
one did believe that you know turning
the clock back on this
curtail women's ability to become
educated rich and well known in an
attempt to make them more happy in a
relationship
right exactly sorry women no more
education for you yeah
get back into the uh the kitchen um it
you can't put that back anyway even if
somebody were to want that so
it's just kind of something that we have
to contend with as a species we've had
many changes very quickly um most
recently we're dealing with social media
and
uh and dating apps and
you know people
having the ability to have what looks
like infinite swipes
and endless options and to specify their
you know their criteria for what they
need whether it's height or income or
whatever
um
when i think when people meet in real
life
it doesn't really work like that
attraction happens i mean proximity just
being close to someone geography think
about anyone that's uh worked in an
office environment you end up with the
weirdest crushes on people yes why am i
if i saw this person out on the street i
wouldn't even look at them twice exactly
because i'm around them all the time
this proximity effect just means
i don't know i get this weird
something yeah exactly and that really
happens that really is the way that
attraction often works um and these
dating apps
take that out of the equation they don't
even give that the opportunity to happen
they also lead people to
really if people weren't selecting
based on looks first before
they really are now all you have is this
tiny 2d curated
image of someone to make your first
you know decision
what have been some of the changes that
have occurred since you've been
researching the incel community
have you noticed the community sort of
grow or shift or morph at all
yeah i think there's been
a lot of changes
to it um
but
you know it hasn't been around that long
to begin with uh so it's kind of hard
for me to say
yeah yeah and what's also just cyclical
natural ups and downs i mean there's
just been a lot more attention on it
since i started um
by media academia security all these
bodies um
and then
there's also been a lot of censorship so
when i
started the research there were a few
issues here and there
um the main
subreddit for in cells
had been banned in 2017 leading to this
website um that's now like the most
popular one but since
that time but there were others and
since that time they've all been banned
in the last
two years a little less than two years
they've all been banned so
it's really leading to
a different i mean i think it just
changes the
nature of the community when
everybody kind of is funneled to one
place and
um and when there's so much scrutiny
that would change the content in the
forum i think to be a little bit more
paranoid some people become a little bit
more
shocking and edgelordy because they
realize reporters and things what's your
loading
an edgelord is someone who uh you know
is edgy online who
will
make provocative comments
okay but yeah i mean as soon as you
drive a community or a movement
underground it's going to become more
subversive
i know that we've both spoken to andrew
gold and he was saying that one of the
or the number one risk factor for
non-offending pedophiles is sort of
stigmatization by society
that if they feel like there isn't a
place for them in society then why am i
playing by your rules what's the point
yeah
and i suppose that you get the same here
that if you feel like you're being
ostracized by society at large well all
right [ __ ] it like i'm gonna say the
meanest stuff i'm gonna come up with the
darkest memes i'm gonna be the edgiest
edgelord that i can because like there's
no place for me there so i might as well
craft out a place for me here yeah and
for people who are already kind of on
the
on the border to where they have a toe
into
a fringe community um
that might be extremist or whatever
um and
usually we'll come with like a kind of a
persecution narrative that we're being
persecuted and they all want us dead and
just like most french communities have
um
that for people that are actually
leaning toward believing that that's
just all the more confirmation that
society wants nothing to do with you
they might be dead
so where are they speaking now if the
subreddits have been removed and
everything else has been chopped away
have they gone to the dark web or
discord servers or what they speak a lot
on discord um the their main website uh
intils.is currently it has domain
changes occasionally for a lot of these
reasons censorship and things like that
various governments um
so that's the biggest incel site um and
i talk with those you know the
administrators of that site a lot on the
on the show
um
and then there are there are a few
others you know um that usually kind of
start up and
fall down or splinter pretty quickly
so the most recent sort of high-profile
in-cell news story that we've had was
here in the uk
yeah the guy from plymouth jake davison
who there's sort of some debate around
exactly how he was motivated to commit
what he did what were the contributing
factors and you wrote this really great
article for unheard which will be linked
in the show notes below if everyone
wants to go and check that out what do
you think the press got wrong about the
jake davidson situation
um i think they got it all wrong
um
i just
think that
some of it probably kind of knowingly um
in terms of how connected he was to this
community i i don't think that that was
um you know he did have a connection to
it i would consider him an insult most
incels probably would he never
um
never called himself that he actually
made an effort you know to kind of
distinguish himself from them and he was
also um active in
some
subreddits that were anti-in-cell or you
know about wanting to debate and cells
would prove them wrong
um
he was just seeing back and forth with
regards to that um
so you know that's that's very basic
point number one uh
like because then if you're going to say
well
he was an incel
even though he didn't call himself one
he didn't identify that way
um but this is what led him to kill
you you just can't do that um with that
kind of definition
but um
you know i think that they're they're
missing some things i think that
uh for me reading it it seems like there
was not evidence that this was even
planned necessarily there was no
manifesto there was no leakage there was
no
um looking for information about like
location or individuals um
i can't even tell from what i read and i
read all has read it and everything um
that he was even necessarily
like suicidal in an acute way that he
hadn't been on and off for a long time
uh i think he was he had mental health
issues he was a gun owner he had an
assault um he seemed to be using uh
performance-enhancing drugs
steroids um from his his post history
um
so you know i think that there's just a
lot um missing
from that
story uh
and then
i also think that
the conversation very much became um
are we going to call this terrorism and
why don't we and
um
i just don't know what that would even
do what it would really help because
yeah
this was this was quite a
strong talking point that i guess aligns
with the oppressor repressed victimhood
narrative everything needs to be
systemic it can't be an individual and
that idiosyncratic peculiarities about
their personal life it has to be
this sort of tip of the iceberg of this
emergent substructure from a group that
from a group that everybody knows is
wrong and out group that's close enough
to our in-group for us to be able to
hate them and quite quickly there were
these talks around
this is a man that hated women he was on
websites that are misogynistic and
very very dangerous and this should be
classed in exactly the same way as
somebody that wanted to go out and shoot
white people or shoot
disabled people or whatever that it
should be classed in that way let's say
that jake davidson had been a full
red-blooded in-cell edgelord from the
depths of one of those forums
do you think that that would have
justified classing it as a terrorist
attack
i don't i don't think that's i don't
think it meets that definition i mean
you could call that possibly a hate
crime if the targets are women or
something like that
i would say that that could apply but
terrorism has to have a political aim
and i don't think that
any of the in-cell attacks have had a
political aim i just think that that's
the wrong word the wrong
set of expertise and and resources to
devote to this issue because
you know people that know about
terrorism and counter terrorism
it's it's different it has a meaning it
has a very specific meaning you know um
and this just does not it's not
commensurate too you could argue perhaps
that some of the men in these groups are
trying to send a message to women that
if you reject us
that we may
we can strike back this is a way that we
can take power don't you forget that men
are stronger and with guns we can be
stronger several hundred times over
i guess you could um
but
i just don't think that
i think it's a stretch uh
you know to call it terrorism in the
first place um
i don't think it would be the right you
know i think that this is a problem and
and problems with having
uh
let's say it's it's not terrorism let's
say it's not even violent extremism but
just extremism just you know fringe
misogynistic group i think that um there
are things about that in and of itself
that
i would consider dangerous and very
unhealthy um and i think that it should
be
handled if that's really like the
motivating factor or even if not it
should be addressed um
with there should be some approach some
actual
you know scientifically
sound and thought through approach to
dealing with
this problem and with the problem of
people being sort of pulled into
um
very dark ideologies
there's there should be and this is a
group of people that
um also would just benefit even if they
are like the lone wolf or just someone
on a downward spiral
that maybe would have benefited a lot
from some kind of intervention but i
just don't i don't think it's terrorism
i would agree that deploying the
counterterrorism unit like jack bauer
isn't going to be able to make
much of this jake davidson situation
you're right that if you have a very
particular set of skills
and those are uh counter intelligence
they are collecting assets and working
out you know i mean
when these groups are
having reddit threads shut down and
that's like a big blow to the community
it
they're not operating at the same sort
of level uh and i think that
fundamentally what this comes out of
which is different to most terrorist
organizations
is not
the impetus for why people join is not
because of a shared vision around the
world it's because of the personal
experience of the world which has
resulted in a commonality that they've
been able to bond over yes
yeah
and that might be true for why a lot of
individuals join these other groups too
that they what they really share is a
personal
experience that they're then sublimating
onto this you know
wider problem but
it's this is just different
what about in cells and white supremacy
because i saw that get thrown around as
well far-right hate groups and white
supremacy
is that just the press
churning out the usual talking points
that they sometimes like if you if
patriarchy then sometimes white
supremacy and also far-right hate groups
or is there actually something to this
uh there there is something to it in so
far as the
the language is
um you know borrowed and it goes back
and forth between these communities
because a lot of them
again also they both grew out of 4chan
the the alt right as we currently know
it the young ones um
the memes and everything like that
there's some similarities in that
culture there are similarities in the
fact that they're both uh anti-feminist
to a degree traditionalist
a lot of that i think has crossover with
those personality types that kind of
mentioned before which is why some of
this material would be
more seductive for a certain personality
type so
i would say there's a lot of crossover
also any
any um
you know army in the past any like
a
terrorist group or just hate group or
anything like that now the people who
join are probably going to be like
disaffected young men that don't have a
girlfriend and don't have that much to
lose
so there's just that
have you seen much talk about race in
the groups that you're a part of
yes there's loads of talk about race
um
they use very
uh
you know politically incorrect or you
know offensive
language to talk about it
but it's not racism
in
i know this we get into a lot of trouble
when we try to talk or define
anything to do with this concept right
now and i understand that it can still
be considered racist to say things that
are offensive even if the intention
isn't to offend or isn't hate um but i
would just make that distinction that uh
mostly it's people of other races sort
of talking about themselves um they talk
a lot about women being racist and how
women are
you know more
racist and more picky than men in terms
of their
dating app
matches and things like that
yeah so i think contextualizing the
other sort of language that's being used
in these groups probably changes the use
of the n-word
to
to something else because when you are
being as edgy as you can
using the n-word is almost just like a
it's crazy to think i went on a i went
on one of these new
video hosting platforms you know one of
these decentralized
things
and uh with unmoderated comments and i
was blo i was like wow i can't believe
that people post stuff like this on the
internet i couldn't believe it even
still existed so yeah when you
contextualize stuff like that it does
make sense you mentioned earlier on
that you said it was about 50 50
when you were talking about white
participants of these groups to other
ethnic backgrounds is that right yes uh
at least in like insults dot co dot is
now 50
of the people on insells.com are from an
ethnic minority
and that's um
and that's given the fact that most of
the
uh members are from europe and the
united states so that's even
i would say that's like you've got an
over-representative indian population in
here or like loads of people from ghana
or something like that that are bringing
the numbers up
well right i mean but you'd think that
given i don't know i think it's in the
united states still something like 70 or
so percent is white europe's probably
similar so you know the majority of the
members are from those
countries then that's definitely not um
i don't think that's over-representing
yeah so proportionally
you have an over-representation of
minorities in this group maybe even a
little bit yeah
that's interesting yeah
it is
this is a
if it's correct i mean how are you
judging that have they got some sort of
self-reporting thing when they sign up
with their profile and have you been
able to drill these data they yeah they
do
i mean this is one of the first things
that kind of interested me was that they
take they were doing this of their own
community these polls
um every six months
that were long and were great questions
and you know we'd get
sample sizes that like most academics
could dream of like you'd never be able
to get this if you were outside of the
group yeah exactly uh so and i and i'm
pretty sure people answer quite honestly
there
that's crazy so i mean this is this is
another one of those
i suppose challenges where a victimhood
narrative
and the uh
current popular viewpoint of the world
kind of the intersection starts to clash
up against itself right that
you're supposed to be helping people
that are in minorities but this is a
minority group which is also a man this
man is part of the patriarchy there's
there's something else as well there's
an x factor that i don't think we've
touched on yet and it's not an x factor
it's like an ick factor
this is sort of there's something about
the group
that causes society at large
to feel have you
sort of considered
why this is yeah i mean i thought about
that a lot because uh
it's so it was so striking when i first
started the
podcast the reactions people would have
and really they're just people just did
not want to hear anything about it they
just didn't want to touch it and
and i noticed that from
from men
at first at least a little bit more than
women even
um
and
you know i've i've asked about that
one incel who's been on my show
uh very early on had a good theory which
was that
um part of the reason people are so
uh
they have such a visceral reaction to it
because i asked
him that too was that
um
well because we're the people that they
always
teased you know when they were kids in
school or whatever and kind of
suggesting that uh having to to look at
this would mean having to acknowledge
that they have been shallow and cruel
and i think that there might be an
element of that and then i think that
there's also just like
the sense that it's like contagious and
people just don't want to be
associated with that thing with this
undesirable you know annoying virgin
loser creepy guy
and
so there's just a real aversion to it
well on top of that as well
i think that there's a sense
there's no prestige associated with
supporting this group
so what you might see
um from somebody
supporting an obviously
um an obvious minority someone that's
disabled let's say like look at me look
at how valiant i am i am supporting this
marginalized group
and this is a comment on my moral
grandstanding as a human whereas like
who's gonna stand up and give the guy
that supports guys that can't get laid a
pat on the back like it just seems like
i i think as well and i'm sure that this
appears in the groups but
there's also a sense of
there's something wrong with you
if you can't get a woman that this is
something fundamental that men are
supposed to do
exactly
that there is a
almost a sense that they deserve it in
some way i'm sure oh yeah and though
people will say that explicitly like oh
you must deserve it
so i mean in a way that
in a way that that that does kind of uh
at least confirm some of the incel's
feelings about this which is that
um in our society
to
it's still kind of like acceptable to
make fun of song for that you know
uh it still suggests that there is
something very wrong
with a person who can't and
and so much so that the people are even
afraid to say
anything you know um
in defense of them
i was talking about this a cricket match
the like the most british way to have a
conversation about about sort of uh
social norms we were talking about the
fact that if you were to
uh sing a racist chant
uh that would be newsworthy right there
would be an investigation it would be a
hate crime um and the
the summary of that is that
we don't want people to um feel sad
because of
an immutable characteristic that's part
of them
but that
that level of protection
only extends so far so if you started
making jokes about somebody or if you
started a chant about somebody being
ginger
that wouldn't be classed as being
protected or for instance the example
that we heard was we were at a game and
there was a player there who apparently
recently had either split up with his
wife or his wife had been caught
cheating on him or something like that
and this chant came up about like
where's your wife at
to to this player now
let's say that that player was a
minority i'm pretty sure that the one
that would have hurt most would have
been the chant about his wife which is
very
pinpoint and it's a it's a pain trigger
exclusively for him yeah it's absolutely
cruel yeah um and it feels like there's
some sort of resonance between
the protection that we have
uh and the lack thereof within the intel
community
do you understand what i mean yeah yeah
you're i don't know it's like
um there's kind of like this men should
be able to take that kind of joking uh
on the one hand
um
and
if they you know
certainly it should be joking because
they should also be able to handle a
woman and this and that
so there's there's that which is very
much playing into the whole traditional
uh gender norms
for one which is part of why it's so
hypocritical um and then
that if they can't they're just whining
and complaining and like you know
get a hobby go to the gym
stop whining
but
that's not consistent with the idea that
men should be able to express their
feelings their hurt
um or that we should be very sensitive
not to
um to punch down
on someone's either immutable
characteristics or just circumstances in
their life that are
not things that any of us
want
yeah it's like it's okay to talk
but not about the fact that you can't
get laid like it's okay to talk is the
mental health campaign that's going on
in the uk at the moment and you think
well
yeah there's something about it there's
some sort of blind spot
i mean i'm i'm feeling that and
especially as i've been reading more
about this in preparation for speaking
to you and just generally i was quite
sort of
fascinated by the the community overall
um
my empathy is is quite conflicted here
because i really really do feel and
hearing the guys talk on your show
they're obviously you know really
sensitive humans for the most part i
think you've had some that are
a little bit more sort of on the
psychotic end yeah
of the spectrum but for the most part
these are just
lonely guys that you want to take under
your wing and go look dude like come out
for a beer
it'll be sweet like we'll just go for a
beer and and it'll be fine um
and on the flip side
there's a challenge because
some of the
as you get deeper and deeper into some
of these communities the fact that you
can have
quite dangerous narratives around women
that
the coping mechanisms that some of these
groups have used i.e sort of this
in-group group hatred of women and then
also of whatever the normies the chads
that's something really isn't so
deserving of empathy but you can
if you've tracked this step by step you
can see where that comes from yeah have
you found yourself i mean i know that
you've previously been criticized for
being too empathetic with these
individuals is this something that you
battle with internally
um
maybe a tiny bit but pretty rarely
because
like i
i don't really battle with my
actual position on it
um
because i i really do feel that
um with anyone that
believes in like a malevolent ideology
with like a designated enemy and
that that did they weren't born that way
that did
start somewhere
there's something missing for this
person and
all of the evil that can come from that
if we really want to stop that
then
coming
approaching us from a place of
understanding that these are actually
human beings and that they're unhappy
and that you know i think it would also
end up
um keeping us all more safe in the long
run i really do i don't think that like
you can silence and shame and shut these
things out of existence
um so
no but there there are times that uh i
just get really fed up with
with reading the things that i read and
with the attitudes i get sometimes why
did you get why'd you get fed up
um
well because some of the things are
horrible i mean like
horribly uh misogynistic and
you know
um
the
you know it you do get sick of it
sometimes like it's funny because i i
read
from all these people that work
encountering violent extremism and
things like that and they they talk
about how difficult it is for them to
just read this content and oh god i
can't i don't feel that way like i don't
find it like
traumatizing to me to read things from a
form i just don't but um
i can
i can find it like there's some days
where i'm just just sick of it
or find it sickening or i'm talking to
an individual who is being
really uh
stubborn and like woe is me and you know
even a little rude to me when i'm giving
them my time and
it's it can just be exhausting um and
sometimes you know the ideas that come
out of it yeah really do kind of sicken
me but
um
i still
think that for the most part any
individual when they're out of their
echo chamber and out of their group is
very different
and
on that level kind of a one-on-one level
um
i don't feel that way toward any of the
people i speak to it doesn't sound that
way either i think maybe there was one
episode that i heard where the guy i was
like wow this guy's really intense um
but other than that most of them most of
them really do just seem like people
trying to find out
answers um there's a quote
from the moral animal by robert wright
i'm not sure if you're familiar with
this book i'm gonna guess it'll probably
be quite popular in in service it's one
of the first big evolutionary psychology
books there's this quote that just
hit me i knew that i had it somewhere
and i saw this jake davidson thing
and thought when went searching in my
read-wise highlights here's the quote
male violence can be dampened by
circumstance and one circumstance is a
mate we would expect womenless men to
compete with special ferocity and they
do
an unmarried man between 24 and 35 years
of age is about three times as likely to
murder another male as a married man the
same age
some of this difference no doubt
reflects the kind of men who do and
don't get married to begin with but
martin daly and margo wilson have argued
cogently that a good part of the
difference may lie in the pacifying
effect of marriage and that was written
in
1993 or 1995
so we're talking on like nearly 30 years
that this has been quite
common understanding
well i think it was a common
understanding and i think now if that
were written it would be met with some
objections i would i would think
maybe the author would be cancelled
robert wrote that book at precisely the
right time but he said that he came from
a
a very uh religious background
and the book is written it's
semi-biographical about charles darwin
and he was like
really really bad i'm pretty certain
that robert's dad is like was really
active in the church or maybe he was a
some sort of pastor or a priest or
something
and he got in he got in so much trouble
uh and it's mad because he's still he
came on the podcast like
five months ago
and he's still going 30 years hence been
just delivering these really incisive
talks
and this book
is
beyond interest it's so good uh it's
really long as well um
and yeah it's so current i i really do
love it but yeah that male violence
thing like of course
of course
why wouldn't you think that there would
be a pacifying effect of having a mate
yeah exactly it's really not that
not that hard to get one's mind around
yeah to have to have an underclass
does anyone in the in cell groups do
they any of them talk about this
situation in china where you have these
entire tower blocks of disaffected men
who are unable to get dates
oh i haven't heard about it in china and
japan in japan there's the hikiki mori
that might be what i'm talking about and
i've just been very pejorative about an
entire nation of people sorry it's fine
i could be wrong too um okay so whatever
that group is have you have you
did they talk about that or have you
learned about that yeah the hikikimuri
um
i would say it's kind of like a proto in
cell
group you know um
in japan uh they're young people not
it's not gendered there though it is
mostly
men um
but
the term doesn't
you know
make a distinction and they don't work
they're not in school they're not
providing for themselves they don't have
like adult relationships and they
basically
just kind of stay home and live off
their parents
this was such a big problem at one point
that
the japanese government actually took a
report of like how many of these people
there were and
there were so many that they began to
refer to the 2030 problem which is what
would happen when most of these
um hikiki mori most of their parents
would die and like how we're going to
provide for these people
crazy
what do you think's next
for the
in-cell community it would appear that
they're being
squeezed increasingly from a
technological standpoint
it also appears that there are
increasingly more
counter cultures
anti-black pill
um
cultures that are coming through i don't
know what the sort of relative
memberships are like
they're still pretty small
um
i think that
you know i really thought that this
problem
would more or less go away not that
incels would but just the this
association with like attacks and
therefore the increased censorship and
stuff would because i i don't know why i
just did um but i i feel like the more
scrutiny there is on this community
i just think that causes more of a
problem um why
because
well
from a purely pragmatic
standpoint let's just say if you're law
enforcement
um
when every big tech platform censors
them they migrate and become
harder to monitor so that's just you
know
one
very obvious problem i think
two is that then there becomes
no um
back and forth with
different perspectives so
more of an echo chamber more of an
extreme echo chamber
um
and yeah it
sort of confirms that
idea of being persecuted and being
having no place in society and then also
for those very few that i believe
are you know maybe violent to begin with
have a fascination with mass shooters to
begin with are just deranged um
then
they know that adding this kind of
cause to whatever they do will just up
the notoriety and there are some sick
individuals that want that so i think
it's a problem in
many ways and
i think that hopefully
there begins to be a little bit of a
change in that conversation
the way that they're dealt with because
this will always be a part of our
society and um
it will always be you know a problem and
a source of grief or conflict for
someone to feel that they have no place
in it and no family and are not desired
and
so those are the deeper issues and need
to look at those
nama cates ladies and gentlemen if
people want to check out what you do and
listen to your podcast where should they
go
um it's called insel and it's the only
podcast called incel
so it's available pretty much
anywhere you get your podcasts um
my twitter for the show is at incel
project and my personal twitter at
domicates that's that's it for social
media and me
cheers thanks
thank you
thank you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that then press here for a
selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few months and
don't forget to subscribe makes me very
happy indeed
peace
you